[Music]
the Twilight movies you're very young
young guy you get in these Twilight
movies and I'm just curious did you have
any idea how big this was gonna be that
you think this is just another acting
gig and then were you blown away yeah I
mean I thought it was gonna be another
acting gig and how I knew it was gonna
be big was one of the first days on set
I was walking back to my trailer and
this this older lady was kind of nice a
older how much like maybe in her early
50s yeah was was calling to me from a
bush and I was like what do you what are
you doing and she's like come here come
here so I I walk up to her and she hands
me this card this printed card that said
Twilight moms and she said call me and I
I just looked at her I said yeah okay
and it was just you just went back down
into the movie and then the bush move to
the side they I have heard about this
phenomenon these older women and when I
say older I mean you know older than you
but they're they they kind of prey on
some of the male Twilight stars it's a
yeah on young guys like me I mean this
one time this older she could have been
my grandma she was maybe in her early
seventies said I will give you the key
to my cabin in the mountains if you
spend a week in there with me and I was
like yeah I have a girlfriend thank you
but no what weekend dude and then you
get the keys here's what sucks for me is
is in the movie I play a human being and
they go hey so who'd you play in
Twilight and I say Oh human being
they're like we're not interested
because they want to be with like a
vampire or werewolf it's always the
vampires and the werewolves that get the
chicks well when did it become a bad
thing to be a human being
yeah I bet you were a zombie now -
that's the hot you know like a zombie or
a vampire but I'm I'm a nice human being
gets you nowhere
nope yeah yeah humans finish last is
this true that your dad was a former
actor he wasn't acted when he was
younger yeah he was like the Macaulay
Culkin of the sixties in South Korea
I gotta think about that for a second
okay I'm processing that he was in the
60s he was the Macaulay Culkin of South
Korea yeah pretty much he had this one
movie where he was inside of this
Godzilla type of monsters ear and he was
trying to knock out the eardrum with
this gigantic q-tip seen in the movie
you make it sound like that was the
whole movie that was the highlight of
him you can't do a whole movie you've
got someone just going well was okay
happy so you've seen his work was good
actor horrible absolutely horrible I
mean he here's the thing he always tries
to give me acting notes and there it's
so frustrating because he'll say the
most obvious things he'll say things
like you need to act more natural I'm
like no crap dad I mean yeah it's called
acting you're supposed to act like a
person so it's it's pretty frustrating
do you ever come back with him like you
know once you go clean Godzilla's ear
[Laughter]